[Music]
I'm Jeff Glor from CBS this morning
Saturday this is the business episode in
the next half hour we'll bring you
stories in the future of Fisheries side
hustle shoppers and betting on video
games we begin with the billion dollar
business of feeding our furry
four-legged friends Dana Jacobson has a
story about new food options for Fido
with ingredients that rival those we
feed ourselves
ground beef potatoes few potatoes and
then just like fresh fruits and veggies
I feel like I'm looking at what you
would make for me yeah but ronaldo web
is actually preparing a personalized
meal for man's best friend it's a little
bit of pumpkin for them yeah I mean this
is actually great for a dogs that have
like sensitive stomachs more than ever
before
pets are being treated as members of the
family and web is betting their owners
will want to feed them that way I was a
consultant working in pet food factories
I saw they were able to use what they
call 4d so dead dying to seize and
disabled like meats
retching making the product I just
didn't feel super comfortable feeding
that to my dog once and so I started
cooking for him he loved the food that
expanded to kind of my close circle of
friends and then peploe really grew out
of that idea we also have our barking
beef our most popular dish for the dogs
the company's meals are designed with
the veterinary nutritionist and made in
a USDA facility for about $4 a day dog
owners can satisfy the foodie in Fido
with fresh meal deliveries portion sizes
are based on weight and activity level
sit Barkley my four-legged family member
and loyal pet plate customer Sherlock
put the dishes to the test oh my gosh I
swear I feed him I feed him really these
are the benefits of fresh human grade
food if let's say it's a hundred and
eighty dollars a month to feed that dog
I'm paying about $60 this is a hundred
and eighty dollars to feed a pet for a
month is it for everyone let's say your
dog is a picky eater your dog has a very
sensitive stomach yourself or very
health conscious or your dog is
suffering from allergies my pet plate
could be a great option for you are you
Michael boy if you
feed a 70-pound dog for $30 a month you
can feed a 70 pound kid for $30 a month
and I would you know challenge you to
think about why you're able to do that
and what ingredients allow you to be
able to do that the fresh food market
for animals is becoming more crowded
[Music]
with companies like fresh pet and just
food for dogs which recently opened this
canine kitchen in Petco's flagship store
founder Sean Buckley says the fair is
good enough for people to eat you can't
go into a kibble factory or something
and actually see the food being made
here they're chopping real vegetables
restaurant-grade meats and they're
making the food right here it's a unique
experience while Millennials are
delaying traditional milestones like
getting married buying homes and having
kids they are adopting more pets and
treating their fur babies like little
human beings animals have now become
part of the family and people have their
dogs sleeping in bed with them they're
traveling
dr. John de Young of the American
Veterinary Medical Association sat down
with us at their annual convention he
says when it comes to diet it's
important to remember that pets are not
people there's still a dog they have
different requirements nutritionally or
behaviorally or anything else for that
matter but that hasn't stopped people's
preoccupation with clean eating in
recent years from crossing over into pet
stores we spray the little pieces down
with a natural bacon flavor take the
gluten free trend which has manifested
itself with labels that scream grain
free capturing attention and dollars why
do people want to have a grain free diet
for their dogs just like grain free
sometimes needs to be popular in people
right now gluten free and grain free
it's a popular myth it's not better for
animals because their nutritional
requirements are not the same as ours
and the consequences could be grave from
2014 to 2019 the FDA received more than
500 reports of canine heart disease
concerned of a potential linkage to
grain free food in July the agency named
more than a dozen pet food brands most
frequently cited in reported cases of
dilated cardiomyopathy or DCM in dogs
which can often result in congestive
heart failure we don't know that there's
definitely a link right so it's
at this point be cautious be cautious
studies are being done and I think more
will come out in the next couple of
months hopefully or in the near future
it seems like every single day there's
two three five new brands of food out
there and diets that say ours is better
because we have this in it
or we don't have that in it and it's
it's really a free-for-all right now so
does there need to be more regulation in
the pet food industry there is a fair
amount of regulation in the pet food
industry could it be better perhaps and
we really want people to know that they
should be taking care of their animals
based on scientific fact and
well-documented studies whether that's
with good old kibble or one of the newer
fresh food meals a trend some say is
here to stay like pet plates Ronaldo
Webb I definitely believe this is kind
of the way of the future when you kind
of look at kind of where the industry's
going and then kind of you know look at
what the human industry have done you
can kind of see them following together
a little bit so I expect that to
continue I expect her to kind of be more
education for people to care more about
what they're putting in their bodies as
well as what they're putting into the
bodies of their family members we do
want to point out that none of the fresh
pet food companies that we mentioned
were cited in the FDA's report the pet
food Institute whose members make most
u.s. pet food and treats said in a
statement they were committed to the
health and safety of our pets more after
the break Americans are expanding their
palates and men are discovering new
kinds of fish to eat the trend is
beneficial in more ways than one
especially when it comes to supporting
local fishermen for this story we went
to Charleston South Carolina when I
first got the Charleston every menu had
grouper snapper salmon even though it's
not from here but there weren't that
many species that people were familiar
with Mike Latta
first opened fig in Charleston South
Carolina in 2003 it is since won three
James Beard Awards and is considered one
of the top restaurants in the world lada
followed fig with the ordinary which
features an all seafood menu nobody was
talking about seafood and here we are on
the coast
this is Charleston how is it possible
people weren't talking about seafood I
think everybody kind of pays attention
to what's trending and
nationally nose-to-tail cooking was very
popular for a decade getting in whole
hogs and learning how to break them down
and I just think for some reason that
was where everybody's attention was
turned seafood was still popular in
Charleston but you know we really
weren't that connected to the people
producing it lada has dedicated his work
to staying as close as he can to the
seafood he serves what is this this is a
yellowfin yellowfin tuna here captain
mark Markov goes boat just brought in a
yellowfin tuna contrast yeah it doesn't
get any fresher than this sliced and
served just off the dock place at the
top of the line right here is for me the
best raw stuff oh yeah oh great right
the sex was really nice very yeah yes
yes tuna is well known other fish are
not anytime we're expecting or demanding
from the ocean the same five or six
species we're not acknowledging the
diversity of the species that are coming
up in a fisherman's net conservationists
like Amy McCown who we met aboard a
small independent shrimp boat are trying
to turn the tide there's so many
underutilized species that are a part of
our ecosystem and can be relied on as a
sustainable source of protein makan
works for good cash a nonprofit that
connects restaurants with local
fishermen that means fishermen being
open to different catches it means
people when there are restaurants being
open to eating different fish absolutely
fishermen are waiting they are ready for
people to say yeah I want I want to eat
scup or a few years ago here in
Charleston it was wreck fish I mean
they're these species out there and
fishermen are just waiting for them to
actually be demanded enough that they
bring something and they bring value
back at the dock McCown says looking
local and in season is key
ideally consumers should also be able to
find out where their fish was caught how
and by whom ninety nine percent of
people who are buying fish at their
local market aren't getting that
information you're right what we see
when people go into the grocery stores
they go to the fruit section they know
they
no GMOs they don't then they want
organics when they go to the beef and
eggs they want grass-fed free-range when
they go to the seafood counter they say
all right what's on sale and so how do
we spread those values of the other
areas of the market into the seafood
counter and that is through having
conversations like this why hasn't that
conversation reached the seafood counter
yet and I think it's because seafood and
fisheries is just so complex in
Charleston progress is being made now in
Lauda's restaurants fish most of us
haven't heard of our hits we can sell
amberjack we can sell porgy Sheepshead
rudder fish there's a host of species
that you would never have seen on a menu
20 years ago that you do now and the
good thing is is that people are much
more adventurous in his kitchen Lauda
cooked us a fitting arrangement a good
way to do it is to go to a restaurant
that you trust and let them make
something new for you okay so this is
cello Bray is direct fish buried this is
a hog snapper with red line ponzu smoked
amberjack pate and then one of my
favorites is the peony trip these are so
clean right sweet
fishing and fish right is the only wild
foods that we eat my interest in seafood
cookery was born from the diversity of
species that we get in on a daily weekly
basis and to imagine my world without
the pleasure of that variety of seafood
I don't know where I would find my
inspiration anyway that's what we do
thank you very much for coming by sure
Amazon makes it easy push a button
something arrives at your door but
behind the scenes that are movers and
shakers hustling to make a profit off
your purchases be right back with that
story
you know the items you purchased online
could have been sitting on your local
store shelves just moments before you
paid for them Michelle Miller hit the
road with bargain hunters who were
shopping just to sell I'm hoping to find
some toys today toy Chris Anderson goes
to great lengths to land a deals logging
40,000 miles a year in his van Anderson
is an Amazon seller practicing retail
arbitrage here's how it works a seller
like Anderson buys an item for a
discounted price in one market like a
store and then sells it for a profit in
another market such as Amazon when
Anderson spots a promising deal he uses
a smartphone app to see just how much
and how often it's selling for online
then he scales up buying it again
and again it all goes into his van and
then to his 200,000 square foot
warehouse in central Pennsylvania once
it sells it goes to an amazon
fulfillment center and then on to the
buyer its bargain hunting on a big scale
in Anderson pockets the profit all of
this here is about $2,000 worth of soy
sauce and I bought it from a trader in
Philadelphia and you're gonna sell it
for probably five to ten thousand
dollars yeah that's a lot of money it is
but it's also a lot of work how far have
you gone to find your deals
oh I've driven all the way down to
Florida all the way up to Maine
Massachusetts I've gone all the way out
to Iowa pretty much anywhere I bet you
found some unusual things oh absolutely
were the more unusual things I found was
a whole bunch of beer tap handles I
found about 200 of those in a store and
they're like 40 50 bucks on eBay and
Amazon and I was buying them for $5 and
sold them all real fast people love them
so it's the unusual yeah it's the
discontinued
the hard-to-find I'm gonna play a game
with you main that item backscratcher
never sold back scratchers fur coats
don't do fur raincoats
oh I've sold a lot of raincoats nose
clippers I saw a lot of personal care
items mousetraps
I've sold mousetraps good moneymaker not
really
some of these will see a 30 $40 profit
on other ones we'll see you 15 or 20
while arbitrage is nothing new outlets
like Amazon eBay Craigslist Facebook
marketplace and Poshmark have
turbocharged the business this great
year I was picking these up for
literally like two three bucks and they
were called - like 15 16 dollars all day
long that's led to an online community
of sellers who are getting in on the
action they are these things today
including my crazy Resendez yeah I think
we might have hit a little bit of a
jackpot here he's been selling products
online for 15 years when I look this up
on Amazon the rink is a hundred and nine
thousand and home improvement which
isn't bad but selling it for 43 25 FBA
would only pay out 33 18 and since we
have to pay 35 plus tax to buy this that
that is a no-go Natalie Z says he's done
five million dollars in sales on Amazon
alone often spending thousands of
dollars on a single shopping trip to
flip all this merchandise we have so
much data available to us as sellers
it's not like back in the day when you
ran a store and you ordered product you
don't know what's gonna sell well I know
what's selling I know how fast it's
selling I know what it's selling for on
average and so I know how much I can buy
there's no there's not a lot of
guesswork involved in it like doing ten
dollars
profit minimum to as much as 600 dollars
in profit in there right there 30
minutes later but rasie takes it a step
further his YouTube channel
breezy resells is dedicated to helping
novice sellers stay in the black top
clearance stuff is down low and up high
like let other people in on how good you
got so what happened was for the longest
time I didn't tell anybody what I did
and I was super like I thought it was
like James Bond right I was super quiet
about it I always wanted to help people
and change the world and then I was like
oh this is how I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
teach people how to make money online
and they're gonna appreciate that and
oddly enough I actually make more money
now that I share information so it's
like the universe just keeps giving back
and that's what I'm a fan of kind of a
pay it forward mentality yeah definitely
and it's paying you back they actually
make more money now doing the YouTube in
the social media then I do actually
selling stuff I didn't really start out
helping people I just started doing it
and then what happened was I would get
messages from people and they'd be like
oh you helped me oh we're in Disneyland
with the kids and it's all because of
you you know people would find me in
public and approach me crying like oh I
paid off my college loan debt because of
you and I'm like oh wow it's something
we saw firsthand on a recent shopping
trip with reason videos I like giving
people tips
as a site income but while folks like
Reesie
make it look easy there are plenty of
risks involved if this is going to be
your actual way of making a living then
there are hard costs that are wired into
the process so it's not just the
warehouse and it's the time and it's
insurance and it's being able to
actually keep track of what you have
it's not for everybody and I think it's
probably not for most people but that
doesn't keep Chris Anderson from living
a life out on the road - I absolutely
love it this has been the best job I've
ever had
slots blackjack poker sports everything
is a betting game in Vegas
how about video games yes that too will
tell you more right after the break
the mecca of gambling Las Vegas is
starting to offer new games of skill in
an effort to appeal to a new generation
they're giving video game players the
chance to test their abilities and win
big cash prizes here's Michelle Miller
I'm not gonna take it easy this time in
his world of gaming hey Blaine great
boys knows how to fix them I'm not
letting you win this time you win it's
for real ok so I won I won a hundred and
eighty dollars cuz we each bet a hundred
dollars and the house took the rate
money so that's how this game works and
that's how we bring eSports to the
casino great boys game Co is the first
company to introduce a new form of
betting on casino floors so how is
essentially your slot machine different
from those of the past a game called we
call it video game gambling and it's
also referred to as skill based games
our games are not slot machine game
you're playing a real video game for
money with titles that might sound
familiar like Soul Calibur one of the
most successful game franchises
or Terminator 2 Judgment Day his goal to
attract a different crowd our average
customer is about 30 to 35 years old and
that's a good thing that's a great thing
for casinos so slot machines make about
80% of gaming revenue for casinos but
the average slot machine player is a 55
to 60 year old female customer so we're
bringing in new younger customers that
are playing gambling games at the casino
of the more than 42 million tourists who
came to Vegas last year 38% were
Millennials therefore one-of-a-kind
experiences at restaurants clubs and
concerts that means fewer people are
hitting the casino floor just 74 percent
compared to 90 percent twenty-five years
ago well there's a slot machine whether
it's gaming it's all about us connecting
with our audience
Lavelle Walker runs MGM's worldwide
competitive gaming division kids grew up
playing Nintendo 64 versus my parents
who grew up playing an atari walker's
betting on game code to make a
difference in profits he brought the
machines to the MGM Grand and park MGM
in October legend sees the Millennials
gonna start taking over this industry so
we need to direct our efforts to this
new cohort of people you're telling me
Vegas will look drastically different in
another 10 years absolutely as far as
the product as far as the way that we
orient our floors everything about the
landscape of our industry will start to
change over the next five to ten years
game goes first test run came back in
2016 with Caesars in Atlantic City
a contract that was not renewed but gray
boys has expanded to other states with
new games like Steve Aoki's neon dreams
on a future tech geek techy and
pop-culture icon with 8 million
Instagram followers and packed houses
across the globe fewer people are as
connected to younger Millennials than
mega DJ Steve Aoki I'm like rolling the
dice I'm like you know I like the
experience of being on
the casino floor and finding a way to
merge those two worlds together and to
your music yeah you know you don't have
to be the fifteen-year-old kid playing
fortnight in the bedroom like say mom
leave me alone I'll come later for
dinner like everyone that picks up some
sort of way to like entertain themselves
you know this is for them it's also for
like almost the demo that comes to my
shows too because when they leave the
show they're like okay I can I could
play this skill-based kind of game I
just said go back to that question of
why someone would pay money to play a
game they can play home here at g2 we
were launching our new multiplayer arena
so now you could come to a casino and
play video games in a tournament with 32
or 64 people and win big prizes right at
the casino that's something you just
can't do at home but with new types of
gamblers come new concerns for me a
gambling was recreational for the better
part of my gambling career so does it
speak and then one day it wasn't Ted
Hartwell is among the 1 to 2 percent of
Americans dealing with a gambling
disorder he's also on the Nevada Council
on problem gaming which encourages
responsible gambling the main focus
right now needs to be concentrating on
making sure that we're not marketing
these types of Galan gambling machines
to minors and also that the people who
are playing them are aware that the odds
are still in the houses favor
no matter what we want to make the games
engaging but we're not out trying to
addicted no kind of gambling all of our
games are only in licensed casinos you
have to be 21 so no kids are ever
playing this game and we actually did a
study last year about how people
perceive the balance between chance and
skill and our games and they see these
games very similar to how they see
blackjack so ultimately these games are
no different than the games that are
already in the casino game Coe is
looking to increase its footprint in Las
Vegas across the country and overseas
what's going on graybow sees it as a
win-win for both the house there you go
and thrill-seeking better is alight so
the blue ones you have to shoot twice
just like a gamer would do you think
there is a point in time the slot
machines won't be on a gaming floor I am
a huge fan of slot machines they're
never going to go away completely but
the great thing is they don't have to
there's plenty of room in casinos for
new kinds of games that attract new
different audiences and these things are
going to live together forever you can
find news and more stories like this
every week on CBS this morning Saturday
and join us right here on CBS n for live
coverage of news 24/7 available for free
across all platforms I'm Jeff